so you're also
i mean you're widely acknowledged i mean
outside of your science work is
being one of the greatest educators in
the world
and feynman is famous yeah for
for being that is there something about
being a teacher
that you've well it's it's very very
rewarding when you have students who are
really into it
and you know going back to feynman at
caltech i was taking these graduate
courses and
there were two of us myself and jeff
richmond who's now a professor of
physics at
university of california santa barbara
who asked lots of questions
and a lot of the caltech students are
nervous about asking questions
they want to save face they seem to
think that if they ask a question
their peers might think it's a stupid
question
well i didn't really care what people
thought and jeff richmond didn't either
and we'd ask all these questions and
in fact in many cases they were quite
good questions and feynman said well the
rest of you should be having questions
like this and
i remember one time in particular when
he said
you know he said to the rest of the
class why is it always these two
aren't aren't the rest of you curious
about what i'm saying do you really
understand it all that well
if so why aren't you asking the next
most logical question
no you guys are too scared to ask these
questions that these two are asking
so he actually invited us to lunch a
couple of times where just the three of
us sat
and had lunch with one of the greatest
thinkers
of 20th century physics and so yeah he
he rubbed off on me and
so you encourage questions as well
convert courage questions you know and
uh
yeah definitely i mean you know i
encourage
questions i i like it when students ask
questions i tell them that
they shouldn't feel shy about asking a
question probably half the students
in the class would have that same
question if they even understood the
material enough to
ask that question yeah curiosity is the
first step
of uh absolutely of seeing the beauty of
something so
yeah and the question is the ultimate
form of curiosity
you